rührende Geste vom Nord mazedonischen
präsidentens devo pentarowski weil ein
Kind mit Down-Syndrom an der Schule
gemobbt wird bringt er das Mädchen
persönlich zur Schule setzt so ein
Zeichen gegen Mobbing und für Inklusion
das elfjährige Mädchen emble hat das
Down-Syndrom und wird in der Schule
deshalb schikaniert und gehänselt und
das nicht nur von den Mitschülern einige
Eltern verlangen sogar sie von der
Schule zu verweisen
präsidenz devo pentarowski davon erfährt
will er ein Zeichen setzen und die
kleine und ihre Familie zu unterstützen
er besucht das Mädchen in der
Heimatstadt Gostivar im Nordwesten des
Landes und begleitet sie
höchstpersönlich zur Schule in der
Schule angekommen bekräftigt er dass
alle Menschen auch in Nord Mazedonien
gleich sein
wir müssen unser Bewusstsein dafür
schärfen dass Menschen mit besonderen
Bedürfnissen ein Teil von uns sind und
wir sie nicht ausgrenzen dürfen
mittlerweile kann emble wieder in ihre
Klasse zurückkehren und wird dort mit
den anderen Schülern unterrichtet um das
weiterhin zu gewährleisten hat sie nun
einen persönlichen Assistenten
zugewiesen bekommen
[Musik]
devo pentrowski der Präsident Nord
Mazedoniens der das getan hat der so
eine Vorbild sein möchte für die
Menschen die imler ausgegrenzt haben ist
jetzt explosiv bei uns spricht mit uns
über diese tolle Aktion schön dass Sie
hier sind guten Tag sie sind selbst
Vater ich möchte sie jetzt nicht nur als
Politiker Fragen ich möchte sie als
Vater Fragen als Mensch fragen was ging
ihnen durchs Herz als sie von Emla
gehört haben
ganz ehrlich ich war wirklich entsetzt
als ich über diese Geschichte gehört
habe ich habe diese Geschichte in den
lokalen Medien gesehen und war wie
gesagt Entsetzen und ich spreche jetzt
auch als Mensch und als Vater und auch
als ganz gewöhnlicher Mensch wissen Sie
es ist natürlich nicht meine
verfassungsmäßige Verpflichtung so etwas
zu tun aber meine moralische
Verpflichtung als Mensch war es schon
das war tatsächlich die treibende Kraft
hinter meinem Verhalten
was glauben Sie was konnten sie ja damit
auch bewirken sie haben natürlich
gezeigt dass sie Vorbild sein können
aber was haben sie auch bewirkt vor
allem bei den Eltern die eine Petition
unterschrieben haben dass dieses Mädchen
nicht in die Schule gehen darf haben Sie
gemerkt dass da ein Umdenken stattfindet
kann sie mit denen ins Gespräch
ich habe mit vielen gesprochen und habe
auch viele Reaktionen aus aller Welt
erfahren und das war letztlich die
stärkste Botschaft und das ist auch die
Botschaft die wir in die Welt hinaus
schicken können nicht nur an die
Menschen in nordmazedonien wissen Sie
diese Art von Problemen sind vielleicht
auf individueller Basis lösbar aber ganz
generell betrachtet sehen wir solche
Probleme ja überall nicht nur in meinem
Land auch in ihrem Land überall in der
Welt und hier können die Probleme nicht
nur durch Einzelaktionen gelöst werden
es muss tatsächlich gelöst werden in dem
wir alle gemeinsam aktiv werden mit den
staatlichen Behörden und mit den
entsprechend eingestellten Menschen denn
es gibt wirklich schwer wäre
schwerwiegende Probleme in diesem
Bereich es gibt so viele stigmatter die
diese Menschen immer noch begleiten
berichtet was sie erleben musste was in
ihrem Herz vorgeht wie sie das alles
erlebt hat und wie sie darüber denkt
das ist eine
ziemliche schwierige Situation natürlich
für Sie diese junge Dame
dieses
junge Mädchen sie hat ein paar
Schwierigkeiten zu sprechen und es ist
auch schwer für sie schon zu verstehen
was man ihr sagt das heißt diese Art von
Emotionen die kann sie ihnen durch
Gesten beispielsweise verständlich
machen und das wichtigste für mich und
alle in ihrer Umgebung war tatsächlich
dass sie gelächelt hat wieder sie hat
wieder gelächelt das haben sie geschafft
ich kann mir vorstellen in dem Moment in
dem der Präsident eben mitkommt dann ist
alles gut erstmal an der Schule aber
dann ist der Präsident irgendwann wieder
gegangen kommt das Mobbing dann wieder
und falls es wieder kommt dürfen die
Eltern wieder bei Ihnen anrufen
absola Abtenau no Sascha jetzt essen
keine solchen Nachrichten mehr zu mir
gelangt oder zu den Menschen die in
meinem Büro arbeiten aber ich glaube das
Problem ist jetzt erst einmal gelöst
wenn nicht dann werde ich natürlich
wieder in die Stadt gostheber fahren und
werde dort wieder mit all den Menschen
in ihrem Umfeld sprechen von der Schule
bis hin zu ihrer Nachbarschaft so etwas
soll nicht noch einmal geschehen nicht
nur ihr sondern allen Menschen hier in
unserem Land
sagt FeWo penrowski der Präsident von
nordmazedonien wird die kleine emmler in
die Schule begleitet hat nachdem sie
gemobbt wurde ausgegrenzt wurde und dort
fast nicht mehr hingehen konnte vielen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie mit uns darüber
gesprochen haben
vielen Dank auch an sie ja